hello everyone it's it's really pleasure
to meet you all
so today we are meeting as an
orientation session for the
2022 lbr environment
and nepea virtual summer programs so in
this summer programs as we've been
discussing about different topics and
different curriculums i think a great
question would be like what is the right
fit and
how they are categorized
so a little bit about that so the
introduction to bioinformatics program
that we discussed uh
first is a beginner level program that
has
sessions designed to take you through uh
big data and then take you through the
ole mix technologies you'll learn about
genomics you'll learn about
transcriptomics and you'll have access
to a lot of asynchronous material which
will make this a lot easier for you to
learn at your own pace at your own time
and at your own convenience
we will have live sessions uh for
queries q a's and we will also go
through some specific case studies that
will help you understand about the
specific research um may that be genomic
research that how it can be applied so
that's one of the key advantages of
mixed logic training is just not based
on you know
the
technology itself but also the case
studies and how
it's applied for research and now um
again
the first program that i discussed and
the second program which will be on uh
data analysis uh biomedical data
analysis using rn python is a again a
beginner level and an also an
intermediate level training program so
for this r and python
i mean we need to understand that where
this is applied and especially in the
context of research so you'll see a lot
of publications published
recent publications in nature cell and
science and all the good journals are
out there
high impact journals they use a lot of
visualization which are really
compelling to look at and also at the
same time one can understand that what
this experiment is all about and how
how can you
actually visualize a huge amount of
information into a small piece of you
know i would say art so this is where r
and python are really really massively
used and there is a lot of application
hence in bioinformatics and biological
research so it's a great program for
beginner level who have not experienced
this and have not been using this for
their own publications reports and all
of that
a is a good fit now um the
transcriptomics for chronic diseases i
mean as the dagger said transcriptomics
uh is a very important topic in today's
uh modern uh era in biomedical research
so it is uh the transcriptomics research
is again a beginner and an also an
intermediate level uh training program
uh which because all of these training
programs have a
very basic introduction
that allows anyone from any background
to actually learn about the topic but
obviously basic biology molecular
biology is something that we expect you
to know a little bit and uh then uh one
of the biggest
you know expectations that we will have
if you're a beginner level is to
complete the asynchronous coursework
because they are they are not just like
any other courses they are more like
practical tutorials that will help you
like to go through a case study that
will help you to understand that how
this is connected with the tv info
server and how can all of this can be
conceptualized into uh you know um
research into a research project and
that is what i wanted to discuss today
in the session now the last
level which is i would say
an advanced level because you will have
to work on a project and
i think many of you who are thinking
about the project has already some ideas
in their mind um maybe it's related to
the
research that is ongoing or some of the
new technologies that you're hearing
about or it could be about the lab that
you're working in and you have some
specific interests and specific ideas
that you wanted to explore so it's it's
an amazing amazing program this research
fellowship i would say because
it's like an experience that takes you
to use the high grade training research
tools and then you get to do the
hands-on analysis and then work on work
and apply multi-omics data or any sort
of data
that is publicly available to these
different research fields so it does not
stop you to work on a very specific
research field you can
have any of the research fields that
that are out there that uses biological
data and generate a research idea and
work on that idea but obviously there is
a requirement for you to know how to use
the t-bind for platform you don't know
how to use rn python maybe for
visualization you don't know also how do
you come up with you know research um
question that is one of the biggest
biggest roadblocks to work on a research
uh
research project so i mean this entire
research uh omega logic research
training is uh very well structured and
uh i would say this is very well
structured because
we have been able to do this in a very
short period of time considering people
will end up doing phds and they end up
doing working for a very long time to
get some of the outcomes that we are
getting in a very quick time and that is
all because of the platform that is all
because of the sim
because we are trying to simplify all of
this uh because this is also a complex
way of you know tr uh of uh applying um
uh and understanding how big data how
this
huge huge amount of information can be
summarized and make meaningful
information insights that really helps
in translational research so big deal
yeah
so that's why we are what we are doing
is that we have this basic coursework
then we have these tools then we have
the platform then we have this research
specialization areas and we talked about
special
case studies that anyone can go through
and learn about the specific kind of
research and then the next the last step
is to start working on your own idea
generate results and interpretation work
with a mentor work with us work with a
team of
collaborators or team of a team of
experts and collaborators across the
world so this is what the research
fellowship training program is all about
and obviously it guarantees some of the
outcomes and that we have been able to
get through this sort of training that
is that people are being able to
highlight showcase and also get results
to
to a level that can be
a preprint that can be a poster
presentation that can be a full uh
full publication
so
more about it to understand that how do
we integrate all of this there is a
there's a
there are collaborators from our partner
universities there are omics logic
research fellows who are already in this
community so we have a community of over
15 000 people who are researchers for
students for faculty who are from
company and uh it's really good to have
like a public profile on omix logic
learn because what we are also doing is
that connecting research projects with
interests in research companies and
companies who are startup companies who
are in pharma so we also have a linkedin
group where i keep on posting and where
we keep on posting about these uh job
opportunities that are associated with a
similar kind of training that you are
that you're getting from this sort of uh
experience
now um what we are working on in a
regular basis is some of these
cutting-edge and modern
research areas where
big data is used where biomedical
information is used where clinical
information is used where even lifestyle
information is used so integration of
all this data and for any sort of you
know personalized care is precision
medicine so
there are a lot of projects that we have
prepared and worked with many students
that specifically discussed about a
certain problem so when it is about
precision medicine then it becomes like
really
about individuals so if you think about
in the context of an individual just
think about the think about the amount
of opportunity that this field is going
to produce because right now it's like
one drug maybe if it's a large and large
number of population maybe like maybe
one drug is
looked at and given to a uh entire
country
but uh
what we have seen and what we have
understood that due to these subtle
changes that we discussed and understood
and while we are learning about
transcriptomics because we are comparing
all of the
uh all of the sequencing and all of the
reads that we get for gene expression
and then we are looking at the genomics
data and then we are looking at the
epigenomics data and then the
environmental factors that we are
understanding from metagenomic data so
it's it's really uh now uh opening up
all of those
correlations that we were not able to
see and we were just guessing so
because of that there's a huge
opportunity in population health and
there's a lot of application in
biotechnology and agriculture and
there's uh this new field called
spaceomics so i can keep on like talking
about this for hours and hours so this
is not enough and there's so much is
going on so these are some of the
opportunities and also like um the
projects that you saw there are some of
the example projects that they put
together that helps anyone to understand
that how this sort of research has been
conducted because they are taken from
peer reviewed publications and as well
as they are taken from data sets that
are available on geo sra all the public
repositories that are hosted on the
amazing ncbi portal
so about the research
the way we are trying to addressing a
research it's more data-driven research
so um when we are doing a hypothesis
based research uh we have some sort of
idea about how this uh hypothesis of
ours will be uh like now uh when we are
looking at this
from a very different prospect when we
are looking at the data first and
understanding that what this data can
answer so that's data driven research
and there is so much of data which is
available out there there is a lot of
opportunity for research so identifying
gaps
and finding those unanswered question
defining your uh question these are some
of the things that we are helping as a
mentor to the research community to the
participants who are joining the
research fellowship program and then
there is a
there is a
strict structure that enables us to
track to enables us to understand that
how uh idea can be you know structured
into a research project can be
structured into a you know a report can
be structured into a publication so this
all of this work goes on when one person
joins the research fellowship and go
through this entire process of
introduction evaluation practice and
then communication is one of the biggest
key to uh having a successful training
out of this so all those who have been
communicating and coming to the meetings
and having this profile that actually
showcases like towards the end when
you're completing your research your
project is also highlighted in your
profile and that enables any of the
employers any of the collaborators to
know more about your research and and
reach out to you for the same
so uh it's very simple to upload this so
we have a mechanism that enables any of
the users to upload their own project
once they're completed their project and
obviously there's a tracking system that
enables us to understand that if you
have reached a level where you can start
a project or not so the the the concept
is to earn ten thousand points and ten
thousand points can be easily earned
when you start finishing the course and
you start running pipelines on tbi and
platform and that will happen when we
start the training programs and before
that we are our objective is for you to
go through the basic coursework that is
available for free and then we will be
able to you know quickly uh go through
these different topics that we are
talking about exciting topics that we
are talking talking about and you to
make the most out of this training out
of this opportunity so some of the
examples we've been working and some of
these students have been able to publish
able to complete these projects that
involves you know working on different
of these research areas including space
omics
[Music]
and its application and seeing how
it affects astronaut astronauts health
and what are the different ways we can
improve and then there are uh like very
specific research which is uh which is
related to precision medicine precision
oncology and
very mechanistic related research so
there is a lot of research ideas that we
can work with uh and working with
already and there are already available
projects for those who do not have a
research idea but would want to work on
a research
research
problem that that sort of opportunity is
also there because of these
collaborative projects so from you know
different levels so we have high school
students who are really inquisite are
into this have able to finish then we
have post doctoral fellows who are using
this for some clinical study and then we
have phd students and undergraduate and
masters students as well completing and
finishing these coursework and the
research project in a very short period
of time
so
i mean some of the recognition that
people have get obviously
not just to go for a better university
and better degree and all of that but
also to win uh prestigious prizes uh
science fairs
and also
to be able to show this in our
omics research symposium that we do
every two years and where we discuss
meet with all the experts in the
industry discuss about the research
recent advancements and give an
opportunity to our research fellows a
platform to research fellows to showcase
their research and get win prizes so
that's all about the research part and
how we are doing this research
fellowship program and along with other
training programs which would make sense
because once you know about some of the
specific training you can easily apply
this to a research project which is also
an option and this is like mostly
available throughout the year but this
is like a unique opportunity to work
with us
within this scope of this program and
also because uh it's available at uh we
are also providing a 50 scholarships
for those who are interested so a great
opportunity for the summer for all of
you and i hope that many of you would
join and start working with us in these
specific areas of research utilizing
public repositories and public data and
our own guidance and the platform and
the community